ich bin mir sicher es wird ihnen nicht
entgangen sein die usa haben gewählt und
donald trump bei den sogenannten mid
term elections ein ernüchterndes
zwischenzeugnis ausgestellt ja zum
ersten mal seit 2010 haben seine
republikaner nicht mehr die mehrheit im
repräsentantenhaus
und wie immer hat der beste präsident
aller zeiten seine ganz eigene art mit
niederlagen umzugehen und twittert
enormer erfolg danke an alle
womit er sagen will danke an mich ja
wobei gut enormer erfolgt das muss ich
ja nicht unbedingt auf die wahl beziehen
vielleicht hat er sich auch zum ersten
mal ohne mit lagen ja eine schleife
gebunden ich meine es kann ja sein waren
nicht dabei und immerhin gehört auch zu
weit im senat haben die republikaner
ihre mehrheit sogar ausgebaut
auch weil trump seine basis mobilisiert
muss man zugeben mit dem üblichen mix
aus angst nationalismus und schier
unglaublichem fleiß seit amtsantritt hat
er pro tag im schnitt 8 lügen verbreitet
so eine analyse der washington post
jetzt kurz vor den kongresswahlen bricht
damit gut 30 lügen am tag sogar seinen
eigenen rekord
glückwunsch 30 flügen am tag da kommst
ja zu nichts anderem mehr wahnsinn
die fleißige hände der nation aber wer
weiß vielleicht wird donald trump jetzt
durch diese halbe niederlage in zukunft
etwas demütiger über der quatsch der
mann ist wütender denn je wütender denn
je
natürlich ab jetzt sind die demokraten
an allem schuld was ihnen schief geht
und die medien natürlich haben sie das
gesehen da hat doch seine freche
knalltüte von fake news sender cnn
kritische fragen gestellt auf seiner
großen sieges pressekonferenz kannst du
dir nach der stunde wieder abholen
ja dem reporter wurde kurz danach die
akkreditierung entzogen
tatsache ist ein ganz normaler vorgang
in einer autokratie aber und das wird in
deutschland gerne mal vergessen trump
hat auch ohne ende fans vor allem bei
den einfachen leuten vom land als
doppelt schon damals vor seiner wahl
gesagt hat so wir bauen eine mauer
da dachte ich der mann ist ein genie wir
haben nicht für ihn gestimmt war der
republikaner ist was war dann der grund
weil er unser erlöser ist
ok den habe ich nicht kommen sehen muss
ich das war überraschend auch für mich
meint ja dabei ist die präsidentschaft
des erlösers vor allem ein eliten
projekt das reichste prozent wird immer
reicher darum geht's und die kleinen
leute werden mit fremdenhass abgespeist
aber es gibt auch gute nachrichten zum
glück im repräsentantenhaus sitzen ab
jetzt so viele frauen wie noch nie ja
vor allem weibliche
so viele frauen wie noch
und vor allem weibliche wähler haben
gegen james partei gestimmt
wegen seiner sexistischen sprüchen wegen
seiner grabl vergangenheit wegen richter
kevin o es bleibt ein rätsel
viele frauen waren gegen trapp das ist
der punkt das ist eine persönliche sache
seine politik ist korrekt dabei
irgendwie mögen sie ihn nicht vielleicht
hat es mit seinem aussehen zu tun ich
weiß auch nicht
nein daran liegt glaube ich nicht
normalerweise lieben frauen
orangefarbenem es muss also doch an
seiner politik liegen
die usa bleiben ein tief gespaltenes
land knapp 70 prozent der unter 30
jährigen amerikaner haben zb demokraten
gewählt
aber bestimmte landstriche sind fest in
republikaner hand bleiben den
republikanern da kannst du im prinzip
aufstellen wenn du willst in nevada zum
beispiel
und dann gibt es insofern eine
besonderheit als das ja ein
bordellbesitzer aber nicht nur ein
bordellbesitzer gewählt wurde sondern
der mann ist auch gleichzeitig bereits
tot
von wegen männer können nicht zwei
sachen gleichzeitig dann hast du
wirklich ein problem wenn du deinen
wahlkreis gegen einen toten pubbesitzer
verliert ansonsten hat donald trump auch
seinen ungeliebten justizminister
sessions gefeuert und wahrscheinlich
kann auch robert maler der
sonderermittler zur russland affäre bald
viel länger ausschlafen
kurz gesagt wieder mal eine bewegte
woche für den präsidenten am ende einer
langen wahlkampfreise
[Musik]
ende
[Applaus]
[Musik]
anstrengende woche
für den präsidenten
und ich prognostiziere jetzt ist
dauerwahlkampf bis 2020 wir von der
heute show haben für die mit hermes
übrigens extra ein wahlstudio
eingerichtet und dort hält ein mann
immer noch tapfer die stellung christian
ehring
sehr schöne vollstudium
ja
hallo es ist ja wahr dass jetzt
eigentlich eine niederlage für trump
oder doch eher ein unentschieden gegen
frage was willst du eigentlich meinem
studio du arschloch wofür man das dem
entschuldigung ich habe jetzt über
wochen diesen unfassbar aggressiven us
wahlkampf verfolgt diesen ganzen haus
die ständigen lügen dieses negative
campaigning ja das färbt ab
wir sind die geilsten reiche leute die
ich mir du musst in deinen spot sagen
die anderen sind der allerletzte dreck
die wollen uns umbringen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die jobstart mops die demokraten rütteln
den ganzen tag an meinem auto rum und
schlagen mir den schädel eingesetzt sind
dumm ist heute schweiz
sie ist gesund ich so geht halt moderner
wahlkampf daraus ein feind der muss
vernichtet werden nicht wie bei uns
diese diese weinerliche pazifisten
scheiße deswegen führe ich auch keinen
wahlkampf gegen andere nicht gegen
andere und genau deswegen verlierst du
im dezember prinzessin lillifee
[Applaus]
warum macht sie das
warum hängt die nicht plakate auf mit
jens spahn trinkt zum früchte pürierte
katzenbabys
können sie mir manchmal vielleicht
stimmt es ja vielleicht christian ich
mache mir wirklich sorgen und schnauze
du fängst du gleich noch eine auch die
wahl studios die wahlstudio sind viel
cooler bei denen in den usa haben sie
dienstagnacht us fernsehen geguckt der
hammer die ganze bude wird zur tollen
grafik vollkommen sinnlos aber so geil
und wie ich meine so sieht doch aus wie
bukarest ev 1982 was sollte besser unser
zdf lässt seine tortendiagramme noch
backen der das stimmt ja in einer alten
tortendiagramm bäckereien 1
man stellt sich vor
dann stellt sich die ständige zwischen
als deutscher da drin ist einfach alles
das alles besser das stimmt doch
überhaupt nicht natürlich dass selbst
der wetterbericht ist hollywood enthüllt
schiri
[Musik]
und dem zuschauer noch sammeln sich
einige chronischem stress kein sieg
gegen die co2 vielen dank
vielen dank für die kraniche liebe leute
ich verlange dass auch bei uns endlich
mal sachen runterfallen ja was maschinen
oder oder oder straßenlaternen oder was
weiß ich ne kuh
[Musik]
usa usa wir brauchen hilfe christian
ehring meine damen und herren
[Applaus]
[Musik]